هل نقترب من توديع الهواتف الذكيه وما هو
البديل المستقبلي
شركه فيرتشو للعلاقات العامه والتسويق
المهتمه بالدراسات توقعت زوال الهواتف
الذكيه في العالم بحلول عام 2030 والبديل
المتوقع النظارات الذكيه القائمه على
تقنيات الواقع المعزز
القفزات النوعيه والمتسارعه التي تشهدها
صناعه اقتصاد الويب زيرو والعوالم
الافتراضيه لاسيما مجالات الميتافيرس
والمستقبل الانترنت اللامركزي وتقنيات
الواقع المعزز تتنبؤ ببدء نهايه الهواتف
الذكيه في العالم
القفزات المتسارعه في مجالات تقنيات
الواقع المعزز ستجعل من النظارات الذكيه
بديلا حقيقيا للهاتف الذكي بفضل حلول
محاكاه الواقعه التي تقدمها والتي نفت
حاجه المستهلكين الى شاشات الكترونيه
للتواصل
[موسيقى]